شات gps برنامج اذا كان الصناعي روبوت
دردشه فائق الذكاء يمكن كتابه نصوص
والمقالات تاليف الاغاني كذلك لكن يبدو
انه خبير في العلاقات الغراميه غير
المشروعه ايضا والقصه تاتينا من بريطانيا
ساره انجليزيه تبلغ من العمر 37 عاما
تعاني مشاكل في زواجها في نفس الوقت الذي
تعرفت فيه على رجل اخر عبر الانترنت
وصل الذكاء الاصطناعي الى حد اختراع من لم
يتوقعه احد من قبل وهو محامي روبوت ليكون
الاول من نوعه الذي يساعد مدعي عليه في
قضيه في المحكمه شهر فبراير المقبل في
الولايات المتحده الروبوت التي تم تطويره
بواسطه شركه تسمى دونات بي يعمل على هاتف
ذكي ويستمع الى الحجج في المحكمه ويصيغ
الردود للمدعى عليه كما يخبره بما سيقوله
في الوقت الفعلي من خلال سماعات الراس
تتعلق قضيه الروبوت الاولى بمخالفه السرعه
تم اصدارها ضد المدعي عليه والذي سيقول
فقط الاشياء الموجهه اليه من قبل روبوت
الذكاء الاصطناعي بعد ان يعالج ويحلل
المعلومات التي يتم الاستماع اليها في
المحكمه فقد تكون تكلفه تعيين محامي
الدفاع في قضيه مخالفه السرعه بواحده
الثمن ويمكن ان تكلف بين 200 الى 1000
دولار اعتمادا على ظروف القضيه وافقت شركه
يونايتباي على تغطيه اي غرامات اذا خسروا
القضيه سالنا الناس في الاردن برايك هل
يمكن ان تستشير الذكاء الاصطناعي حول
حياتك الشخصيه نتابع الاجابات
اكيد انه لا لانه الذكاء الاصطناعي نحن
الي اخترعنا البني ادم اللي اخترعه فانا
قرارات شخصيه راح تكون باراتي انا حسب
حياتي انا قررتي انا
مستحيل اخلي اي شيء انه يتحكم فيها حتى لو
كان ذكاء صناعي او
غيرها
ضروري
فبالتالي اكيد
بخصوص الطلاق
بس لو بخصوص الطلاق على طول يعني ممكن
[موسيقى]
الانسان يعني مولود بالفطره من ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى
مهما تطور ما رح يكون عنده فتره الانسان
بشكل سلبي ما يكونش القرار سليم زي ما
بتخزي انت لنفسك
[موسيقى]
طيب بما انه نحن بلشنا نحكي عن شاديه
واللي صار مع السيد البريطانيه حصلت على
الطلاق بسبب استشرتها لتشارجي
انا مش كثير مقتنعه
انا وانت لازم نجرب شو رايك نحنا نتقمص
شخصيه ساره
[موسيقى]
الاهلي او روبوت تشاد الالي اي سؤال تسالي
برد عليك كان مقالات كان اسئله شخصيه عم
تساليه يعني دغري ردوا علينا يعني احنا
قلنا هاي هالو هالبيوت توداي كيف بقدر
اساعدكم اليوم تمام هلا نبلش نعرفهم عن
حالنا مثلا
اوكي
قولي للناس شو عم تكتبينا دين اهم احنا عم
نقول لهم ان انا نادين
وكيف بقدر اساعدك اليوم تمام يعني كله هذا
التواصل
خلينا نبلش
طيب انا كثير متردده
انا عم بتقاتل مع جوزي كل يوم
معنا عم بتقمص ساره
لاننا نشوف اذا فعلا هيك صار اوكي عم
بتقاتل مع زوجي كل يوم اااه
اوكي
انا عم بقول انه انا شو لازم اعمل هلا
لازم اطلب الطلاق يا ساتر يا رب
اوكي
الاله عم بترد علي انه كثير عم يرده كثير
كثير يعني طيب خلينا شكله انه عم تعطينا
علاج هذه فضيلك الصبح طيب خلينا نبلش انه
يبدو انه انتم عم تقطعي في وقت صعب هذا
الوقت فيه تحدي
واحنا بنقدر نرشدك لنحل هذا الصراع بينك
وبين الشريك ولكن مهم كمان انك تشوفي كل
الخيارات قبل ما تاخذي القرار اللي متعلق
في الطلاق اوكي هذا اولا هلا هي عم تعطيني
زي نصايح يعني كيوتين خلينا نعملهم قبل ما
ناخذ هذا القرار اول شغله انه نستشير سرقه
لا يحكي معنا يعني اخصائي
علاقات عشان نقدر يعني دائما وجود شخص
ثالث ممكن يساعدك انت وزوجك لا تفهموا بعض
كما تقدر تحلوا المشاكل بينكم هذا اولا
اعطتنا هذا النصيحه خلينا نشوف النصيحه
الثانيه اللي اعطتنا اياها انه
يعني طبعا تواصلوا مع بعض خلي يكون في
حوار مفتوح بينكم يعني خلي الامور تكون
واضحه خذوا بريك
اياها
من صنع الانسان
الصناعي
غير الطلاق
بها الوقت
والله لا مش شرط انك تاخذ الايجابي
وبتعملي فيها لا بس من الممكن انك تاخذي
منه اجابه من الممكن تاخذي منه صباح الخير
لكم جميعا ان التهيت
وقلقت على نادين انه ممكن يقول لها طلبي
كنت متوتر نوعا فصباح الخير لكل المشاهدين
الكرام لا الحقيقه
يعني اي اجابه ياخذها منه بطبقها في ارض
الواقع هاي المشكله التحكم
في الانسان واحنا بالعكس الاصل الانسان
يتحكم بالاله همم لكن لكن ما ما هو قادم
هذا هنا المشكله
ما هو قادم هو المشكله يعني هذه نسخه
تجريبيه من تشيل جيبوتي وبالتالي بدائيه
يعني النسخه النهائيه ما وصلت بعدها الى
الحد المطلوب حتى يتم نشرها فعمليا احنا
عم نتعامل مع منصه بدائيه عم تعطينا مثل
هيك اقتراحات
بالبدايه هو اعطاك انسنه واعطاك وحبيت
المصطلح ان ست ندين الانسنه يعني بدا بانه
لازم يكون في شريك ثالث او طرف ثالث يدخل
معكم على المعادله ويحل المساله وياخذ
وجهات نظر فعمليا واخذ نفس الاجراء اللي
بياخذوا الانسان يعني ما ابتعد عن
الاجراءات العاديه النظاميه اللي من
الممكن ان ياخذها اي انسان فانا ما لا ال-
ال- الروايه كيف اعطتها ساره
هنا بيعتمد عليه انه هو قال له حب الروايه
يعني كيف انت بتعطي الروايه كيف انت بدك
تتوقع الرد من هذه الروايه
ما معنى يعني ما في امل
والله انا حبيت العقل هذا اللي عنده يعني
انه بهدي في النفوس
هي هي من الممكن ان يكون الطرف الثالث
يعني في الايام القادمه روبوت اخر يعني
مختص في العلاقات الاسريه من الممكن ان
يكون روبوت طيب من الممكن ان يكون يعني في
في هذه المساله ايضا روبوت ونضطر احنا
نروح للروبوت ونتحدث مع الروبوت وبالتالي
يعطينا حلول لكن هل نلتزم بهذه الحلول ام
لا احنا نبقى الفرق بيننا وبين المشيين
انه احنا في عندنا العاطل فيها في عندنا
الخوف في عنا الولد في عندنا البنت في
عندنا الحضانه في عنا الاهل المحيط
والحكمه خبير في هذا الموضوع خبير امن
المعلومات على اي اساس يعني
المعلوماتنا واسالتنا ويجيب عليها ايضا
على اي اساس كيف
تعلم يعني تعلم
بفتره معينه هو من 2015 حتى نكون واضحين
يعني الموضوع كلياته بدا بال 2015 يعني
سبع سنوات وهم يقوموا على ابحاث معينه تم
تعليم هذه الاله من خلال ضخ مواد ضخمه جدا
وداتا ضخمه جدا الى هذا التطبيق وبالتالي
اصبح يتعلم هذا التطبيق والان هو ايضا في
مرحله تعلم يعني هو الان في ال ال ال ال
النسخه البيرجين اللي بين يدينا هي نسخه
نسخه تتعلم يعني هو طالب يتعلم في المدرسه
تخيلي انت تكمل الهائل من الاسئله اللي عم
تجي وبالتالي الفيد باك ايضا وشو هو عم
بيعطي فهو عم بيع الخوارزميات اللي موجوده
داخل تعمل وللعلم هذا اوف لاين يعني بعده
بالاوفلاين ما طلع اون لاين فعمليا بالاوف
لاين الخوار
تشتبك بالمعلومات مع بعضها وبالتالي بسرعه
فائقه يخرج لنا محتوى معين همم بالتالي
هذا المحتوى اما ان نقتنع فيه واما ان لا
نقتنع هي اليه خوارزميات معينه على داتا
مخزنه سلفا بهذا التطبيق وهذا التطبيق
اصبح قادر على التعلم قادر على ان يطور
ذاته قادر على ان يعطي المزيد كل يوم لا
بل كل لحظه بل لا بل كل ثانيه
وبانتظارنا مخيف يعني ولكن رغم انه عم
بخبره يا استاذ رائد انت عم انك بتحكي انه
خطف الاولاد ومهددني بالقتل الى انه يعني
عم بتعامل مع الامور براويه نوع فهمم لا
ندري ان كانت القصه صحيحه ما صار يبدا
انها لقيتها حجه يعني لحتى تطلب الطلاق
احنا بتشكرك جزيل الشكر من عمان خبير امن
المعلومات رائد سمور